大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
這一集是演講訪談系列,
主角是DHH,
本名David Heinemeyer Hansen,
他寫出了Ruby on Rails,
一套很多知名網站都在用的開發工具,
也是軟體公司SantiSignals的合夥人跟技術長。
2026年9月
美國德州的奧斯汀
他在Real World的開幕演講上
說了一句讓臺下工程師很難不在意的話
他說他的公司已經pencils down
不再親手寫程式了
這一集只問一個問題
當寫程式這件事交給AI
會寫程式的人
還剩下什麼
我先把他答案放在前面
他用畫家來比喻
相機出現以後畫家沒有消失
可是工作換了一種
他覺得程式設計師正站在同一個路口
這個方向我覺得有道理
可是他說的速度跟範圍要打一點折
我們分三步走
先看他看見了什麼
再看他的公司實際怎麼做
最後把這場演講放回現實
核對哪些是實情
哪些是臺上的樂觀
先從一個在臺上
手舞足蹈的人開始
ADH是丹麥人
David Heinemeyer Hansen
這個名字太長
大家都叫他DHH
他在2004年寫出Ruby on Rails
後來跟合夥人一起經營
三子Signal是家公司
做專案管理軟體Basecamp
還有電子郵件服務HEY
在工程師的圈子裡
他的形象很鮮明
講話直接
立場強烈
常常跟主流唱反調
Rails World
或者是RAILS的社群一年一度的大會
2026年辦在奧斯汀
9月23號開幕
DHH上臺
先替自己打了一劑預防針
他說看到一個人在臺上這麼興奮
你的第一個反應可能是想幫他做個診斷
網路上有個說法叫AI psychosis
意思是被AI沖昏了頭
好像中了血
他說他不喜歡這個詞
想換一個
聽他自己怎麼說
AI psychosis
I prefer a different term
I have AI delirium
AI euphoria
因為這是我們讓電腦做的最令人興奮的一件事
在我跟它們合作、玩耍、互動的那一段時間中
他的興奮要從 Rails 講起
Ruby on Rails 是一個網頁框架
框架的意思是
一套事先幫你打好的骨架
你只要專心做自己產品的那一部分
Rails 最有名的一條原則
叫 Convention over Configuration
中文叫約定優於設定
他的意思是
很多事情不用你一條一條寫清楚
只要你照大家約好的方式取名字
系統就自動知道東西放在哪裡
比方說你做了一個叫Blog的功能
網址、程式、頁面就自動對在一起
不用另外寫設定檔
2005年DHH在一場研討會上示範這件事
一邊打字一邊說
看看我沒在做的那些事
後來GitHub、Shopify這些很大的網站
都是用Rails做起來的
所以這20年DHH其實一直在追同一件事
讓一個人少寫一點程式
也能做出完整的產品
這一次他在臺上把那段2005年的影片又放了一次
接著說了這段話
那個時刻到底是什麼
DHH沒有直接講AI
他先帶大家回到200多年前
他用的比喻是肖像畫
在18世紀
你想留下自己的樣子
就要請一位畫家
坐在他面前好幾個小時
再等他畫上好幾個月
畫出來很美
可是很貴
大多是貴族跟王室才請得起
他放了一張丹麥王室的全家福
畫的是丹麥國王克里斯蒂安九世一家人
1886年完成
畫家叫Loris Tuckson
DHH說光這一張就畫了三年
然後相機來了
1900年
Kodak推出一臺叫Brownie的相機
賣一美元
一般家庭也買得起
留下一個人樣子的成本
一下子掉到很低
講到這裡
DHH指責那王室全家福
說了一件臺下沒有人想到的事
畫這張畫的人是他的高祖父
所以這個比喻對他來說是家族的故事
DHH說
Brownie出來以後
Tuxen跟同一個年代的很多畫家都發現
把現實畫得跟真的一模一樣
已經不再是賺得到錢的本事
他們需要另一種本事
有人走向印象派
畫光線跟感覺
像畢卡索
走向立體派
他說技術把舊路堵住
反而逼出了一波新的創作
他也放了一張Tuxen晚年的照片
畫了一輩子肖像的人
自己也做到了相機前面
這個比喻有一條界線要先講清楚
DHH剛的
是轉型成功的那一群畫家
當年靠畫肖像過日子的人
不見得每一個都找到了新路
這一點
我們第三部分會回來看
不過比喻的重點很清楚
一種本事變便宜了
有這種本事的人
價值會移到別的地方
那城市設計師的Brownie是什麼
DHH給了一個很精確的日期
2025年11月24號
Anthropic推出了Cloud Opus 4.5
Cloud是一個AI模型
Opus是它最強的那個等級
這基本有兩件事很重要
它寫程式的能力明顯變好
價錢也降到上一代Opus的三分之一
DHH還用了一個詞
叫Harness
Harness原本是馬距的意思
在AI這裡
指的是包在模型外面的那一套工具
讓模型可以自己讀取檔案
執行指令 修改程式
像Cloud Code就是一種Harness
模型變強又變便宜
再加上一套順手的工具
很多工程師第一次覺得
旁邊做了一個真的能一起寫程式的夥伴
DHH說
那一天對他來說是一條分界線
之前是一個世界之後是另一個
他在臺上是這樣說的
接下來的故事DHH講得很老實
Opus 4.5之後
大家興奮了好幾個月
開放權重的模型也追了上來
開放權重的意思是
模型本身可以下載
放在自己的電腦上執行
可是從今年2月到5月
他說進入了一段幻滅的低谷
幻滅的低谷
是科技顧問公司Gartner用的說法
一項新技術被捧上天以後
常常會跌進一段
大家覺得被騙了的時期
那幾個月新模型一直推出
用起來卻好像沒有更好
有人開始說
AI的進步走到頭了
DHH說
這段低谷沒有像攝影那樣
拖上幾十年
到了六月就結束了
新一代的模型出來以後
它的用法整個變了
以前它是叫agent
做一件小事
agent的中文叫代理程式
是為自己一步一步
把工作做完的AI
現在它可以把一整個問題
甚至一個想法交出去
自己不碰時做的細節
回來看到的
是已經解決好的結果
第一部分先整理一下
DHH看見的是
用他自己的比喻來說
就是程式設計的相機時刻
肖像畫沒有消失
可是把現實化的一模一樣
不再是賺錢的本事
他覺得寫程式也走到了這一步
一行一行親手打出程式
正在變得跟
跟請畫家畫肖像一樣
很好看
但太慢也太貴
而他的整個職業生涯
從RAILS開始
就是在追求少寫一點程式
所以AI一來他不是被迫接受
而是覺得終於等到了
那接下來的問題就很實際
一家真的在賣軟體
也要對客戶負責的公司
把鉛筆放下以後
每天的工作到底變成什麼樣子
答案在演講第20分鐘左右
DHH說
幾個禮拜前
37signals
做了一個決定
我們不再親手寫程式了
他用的詞是pencils down
這是考試的用語
時間到了
尖靠老師和Pencils Down說人把筆放下
在30signals
親手寫程式從日常工作變成一種例外狀態
他還打了一個比方說
親手寫程式
就像在Sentry上看到一個錯誤
Sentry是工程師用來收錯誤通知的工具
系統哪裡壞了
他就會跳出來提醒你
意思是
如果有人用拿起鉛筆自己寫
就代表哪裡出了問題
為什麼Agent做不出我們要的東西
接下來這段
是整場演講裡我覺得最重要的一個想法
我覺得最重要的一個想法
It is like seeing a bug in sentry.
Something here went wrong.
為什麼工程師不可以製造我們想要的東西
好,可能再做一段時間
But then we fix the machine.
We fix the factory.
We get things going again.
修機器、修工廠
這是DHH自己的比喻
以前的工程師
像工廠裡親手做零件的師傅
每一個零件都經過他的手
現在零件交給機器做
工程師的工作
變成照顧這條生產線
機器做壞了
他不是自己去補那個零件
而是去查清楚機器為什麼會做壞
把它調整好
讓之後的零件都對
這個轉變
37GNOS
其實失敗過一次
今年春天他們在港北Camp 5
讓一群設計師直接用AI寫功能
送出二三十個PR
PR是Pool Request
意思是我修改好了一段程式
請大家檢查以後合併進去
每一個PR單獨看都還可以
全部合在一起
整個程式的結構
卻像一塊瑞士起司
到處都是洞
他們當時的結論是
技術還沒準備好
DHH現在說
那個結論是錯的
再多等一下
新一代模型一出來
同樣的做法
大概就行得通
他在臺上請他
在美洲親手寫
大量城市的人舉手
他說
整個會場
大概只有五個人
工廠真正開工
是在HEY
HEY是Signal Signals的
電子郵件服務
原本是一個
網頁應用城市
用瀏覽器打開就能用
DHH說
其實一直不想當網頁城市
他會做成網頁是因為
網頁最省人力
另一條路叫原生應用程式
就是替iPhone Android Windows Mac
這些平臺各寫一套專屬的版本
用起來更快更順
可是要很多人維護
以前一個小團隊
要同時照顧六套原生程式
幾乎沒有人做得到
這一次他們一個禮拜前才開工
臺上已經在播六個平臺的示範畫面
後端也要換掉
後端是使用者看不到
在伺服器上處理郵件的那一半
他們打算用一種叫RUST的程式語言重寫
RUST執行的很快
很省資源
可是寫起來很繁瑣
DHH對他的感情很複雜
聽他自己說
就在這段之前他還說
Rust是40年來最醜的程式語言
叫人去讀它
簡直不人道
可是隻要不用看
他就愛它
這句話很好笑
背後卻是一個很大的轉變
他把AI寫出來的Rust程式
當成一個黑盒子
黑盒子的意思是
你不管裡面怎麼運作
只看輸入跟輸出
對不對
他說
這跟歷史上
每一個請工程師
寫軟體的老闆一樣
老闆也不讀程式碼
他驗收的是結果
差別只是
現在被請來的是AI
他也講了一個成果
照他們初估
新的HEI後端
用的運算資源少了一大截
尖峰時段的流量
甚至可能用一臺Raspberry Pi撐住
Raspberry Pi是一臺信用卡大小的小電腦
這是他們自己的估算
新系統還沒上線
我們先記下來
那他是用什麼告訴AI要做什麼
他的答案
連他自己都覺得意外
英文是比Ruby更好的設定語言
用英文寫程式
意思是用人化描述你要什麼
讓AI去寫
換成我們用中文也可以
那個Rails呢
如果大家都用人化寫程式
Rails還有用嗎
DHH的回答是
Rails那條約定優於設定的老原則
剛好最適合這個時代
原因跟Token有關
Token是AI讀寫文字的單位
你可以先把它想成字數
AI讀得越多寫得越多
就越慢也越貴
一個照約定走的專案
AI不用讀一大堆設定檔
就知道東西放在哪裡
少讀少寫
就省Token
RAILS還有一個目標叫一個人的框架
讓一個開發者就能做完一整個產品
這也正是Agent想幫上忙的地方
RAILS基金會還請Evil Martians
加顧問公司做了一套EVAIL
EVAIL是給AI的考卷
這份考卷看Agent用RAILS
做功能做的好不好
DHH說第一版考卷很快就被考到9成5
只要換一份更難的
說到這裡DHH拿出了這場演講最大的數字
過去21年
他平均一年寫大約3萬行
正式上線的Ruby程式
今年8月一個月
他寫了15萬行
大約是他長期平均的60倍
他自己馬上補了一句
這裡面很多是很囉嗦的Rust
而且是他沒看過的程式
所以行數不能直接拿來比
大家看的是那個數量級
另一個改變比較私人
他放了一段自己以前的影片
影片裡他說
比起放棄寫程式
他寧願退休
然後他說
他已經從職業程式設計師退休了
大概是今年3月左右
他不是說他不做軟體
他每天還在做
只是不在一行一行親手寫
對一個說過
寧願退休也不肯放下程式的人來說
這句話很重
可是他回頭看了25年
語氣裡沒有遺憾
I spent a quarter of a damn century
chiseling code by hand
and loving every moment of it
What a wonderful experience
and productive time in that era
如果故事停在這裡
它是一段很溫暖的退休感言
可是DHH接著把這件事
從他自己推到了所有人身上
他說
親手寫程式
對大多數公司裡的
大多數城市設計師來說
已經不划算了
這是今天
到今年年底
會擴大到幾乎所有領域
幾乎所有人
這是整場演講
最強的一句主張
也是第三部分
要好好核對的一句
我們先聽他原本怎麼說
第二部分整理一下
在三次C-Signals
鉛筆放下以後
工程師的工作變成三件事
第一
用人畫把要做的東西說清楚
第二
照顧那座工廠
機器做壞了
去修機器
不去補零件
第三
把AI寫出來的程式
當成黑盒子
從外面驗收結果
Rails那條老原則
也從替人省力
變成替AI省Token
DHH自己的說法是
大家會從親手課程式的人
變成專業做東西的人
可是這些話
出自一個很會演講的人
在他自己的大會上
對著最支持他的觀眾說
接下來我們把它放回現實看一看
第一個要核對的是時間
DH也並不是一直這麼想
今年1月7號
他在自己的部落格
寫了一篇文章
標題叫替AI Agent升職
他說他以前一直不喜歡
編輯器裡那種AI自動補完
覺得會打斷自己的思考
現在Agent能自己把工作做完
他願意給他們升職
可是同一篇文章裡他也寫
如果要守住品質
還有城市整體的一致性
他做不到有些人說的
九成以上的城市都交給AI
到了5月
他發表Baycam 5的時候
還說這個產品歡迎AI來用
但他們不會跟著Agent的熱潮起舞
從那時候到9月宣佈
鉛筆放下不到4個月
看到新證據就更新想法
本來就是好習慣
可是這也提醒我們
他今天講的這麼篤定的話
是幾個月內形成的
之後也可能再變
第二個要核對的
是到底快了多少
迭去記載臺上說
最差的程式設計師不用AI
跟最強的程式設計師用AI
差距可能到1000倍
這個數字沒有人量過
真的去量的研究
結果複雜的多
2025年7月
一個叫METR的研究機構
找了16位很有經驗的開放原始碼開發者
讓他們做自己手上真實的工作
有些可以用AI有些不行
結果用了AI的時候
他們反而慢了大約19%
而且這些人自己感覺是快了兩成
不過那是2025年初的工具
比OPUS 4.5還早
METR
今年2月想再亮一次
卻碰到新的問題
很多開發者不肯在沒有AI的情況下工作
有的人乾脆不教那些不想手寫的題目
實驗就亮不準了
他們自己也說
真正的加速可能比亮到的還大
所以比較誠實的說法是
AI確實讓很多人變快
可是快了多少
我們還沒有一把好尺
行數也不是那把尺
這一點DHH自己也承認
第三個要核對的是代價
把RUS當黑盒子
對DHH來說說得通
他寫了25年程式
看結果就知道哪裡不對勁
可是黑盒子一多
問題也跟著來
除了資訊安全的漏洞
誰看得懂
過幾年要修改
誰接得住
DHH在臺上也承認
資訊安全是真實的風險
他的回答是
我們有工具
也有AI可以拿來防守
這是一個方向
還不是一個答案
Rail社群裡也有人很失望
開發者Joey de Villa
在部落格寫了一篇心得
標題引了一句話
說這是他經歷過
最讓人困惑的一場告別式
他覺得一個20年來
教大家寫出漂亮城市碼的人
現在說城市碼不用看了
等於丟下了這個社群
還有一個小地方
DHH的提款機的例子
提款機出來以後
銀行櫃員反而變多了
方向
沒錯
經濟學家James Basson研究過
櫃員的工作確實沒有因此減少
因為銀行開了更多分行
可是DHH講的年代跟人數
都跟紀錄對不上
這很像整場演講
方向抓得準
細節講得很快
最後他用這段話替整場演講收尾
這段話很有感染力
可是要看清楚它是什麼
它是一種態度的選擇
不是證據
未來不確定
所以選擇開心
這可以是很好的生活方式
但他沒辦法告訴我們明年工作會變成什麼樣子
那對一般人這場演講有什麼用
回到畫家的比喻
兩面都要看
一面是像Tuckson這樣的畫家轉型
留下了新的作品
另一面是很多靠畫肖像為生的人
那份工作是真的變少了
對正在學程式的人
DHH甚至說太懂電腦的人反而容易管得太細
用初學者的心態下指令
效果更好
這有一點道理
可是他能把RUS當黑盒子
是因為他花了25年
知道好的軟體長什麼樣子
驗收的眼光
還是從親手做過裡面長出來的
就寫程式的人門檻真的變低了
DHH這場演講用的簡報軟體
是他在準備演講的那幾天
請AI做出來的
整個程式只有半個MB
你想要一個剛好合自己習慣的小工具
現在可以試著用一段話
把它描述出來
我們回到開場那個問題
當寫程式交給AI會寫程式的人
還剩下什麼
DHH的答案是
他高祖父那一代畫家的答案
把現實化的一模一樣的本事變便宜了
可是知道要畫什麼
看得出好壞的人
還有位置
站得住的那一半是
是Sanity Signals真的在這樣做
也真的做出了東西
要打折的那一半是
它的轉變只花了幾個月
研究還量不準到底快了多少
黑盒子的帳也還沒算清楚
所以我的看法是
鉛筆可以放下
可是判斷好壞的那雙眼睛
還是要自己練
最後問你一個問題
如果你可以用一段話
請AI幫你做一個只給自己用的小工具
你第一個想做什麼
留言告訴我
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook開啟通知
我們下次見